Perché non la rimettete la carta igienica quando la finite?
Perché? MAMMA!!!
MAMMA!!
Mi portate la carta igienica che è finita?
*fischia
*fischia*
Ohhh.....adesso come faccio?
A mali estremi...
Giusto in tempo per
uomini e donne
nooo
No Maria io esco!!
Cioè è solo business....tremendo!!
Dai ma lui è un cretino....come fa a piacerti?
Marina se non ti piace cambio canale eh. No no no...va benissimo il telegiornale...io adoro il telegiornale
È un nostro diritto essere informari su ciò che succede nel mondo
*pensiero* io odio il telegiornale
*pensiero io odio il telegiornale
Mi è venuto un languorino
Vediamo cosa offre la casa
*pensiero Maronna che famee
Marina hai fame? Ti preparo qualcosa? No no no no grazie non si disturbi!! Ho già mangiato prima di venire qui...grazie
*pensiero* Mi mangerei tutta la casa...te compreso
Dai mamma ma cosa è sta roba?!
Secondo te sono a dieta che mi mangio l'insalata?
Portami la parmigiana della nonna dai..
Marina...ecco un'insalatina di verza
Buonissima la verza! Io la  adoro!! È il mio piatto preferito!
Se ti piace guarda che ce ne  è ancora!
No no grazie va benissimo...Mi sazio sicuramente!
mamma alza il riscaldamento che sto gelando
Marina hai freddo per caso? no,no,no noi abbiamo i riscaldamenti bassi ma se vuoi li alziamo non c'è problema sto benissimo temperatura perfetta
*pensiero* sti tirchi
Marina ecco la tua acqua .
Grazie, gentilissimo.
Molto gustosa...buona!
Basta così.